est-ce que les cérémonies de
reconnaissance de territoire sont
appréciés
oui bienvenue à paroles autochtone et si
c'est melissa maulin depuis cette
semaine je répondre à la question de
karine en deçà en grande majorité oui
elles sont apprécié ce qui peut être
moins apprécié c'est quand elles sont
faites un peu à la va vite sans que la
personne se soit vraiment informés des
fois même je pense que c'est ce qui fait
le ps le plus les gens les gens
s'inquiètent beaucoup par rapport à la
prononciation du nom de la nation mais
ce qui est quitterait plus je pense à ce
raid pour savoir vraiment c'est quoi la
nation c'est ne pas être informés sur le
sujet donc une reconnaissance
territoriale faut comprendre que c'est
une reconnaissance la présence continue
des programmations c'est une
reconnaissance aussi de leurs
responsabilités un rapport aux
territoires non pas de leurs propriétés
comme ses pensées la manière noire
américaine et donc en disant je
reconnais que je suis sur ton territoire
tu reconnais que j'ai la responsabilité
et que mon ma connaissance du territoire
va être la meilleure pour pouvoir faire
des décisions prendre l'édition faire
des choix donc cette reconnaissance de
ce type de reconnaissance à être
extrêmement apprécié ce qu'il est - je
pensé qu'on dit je reconnais que je suis
un territoire moi mais c'est pas ce qui
est en train de dire tu sais pas c'est
quoi la nation mois donc une des
pratiques que j'aime beaucoup c'est
quand en plus de reconnaît la présence
sur le territoire eh bien tu rajoutes un
fait vécu sur ce territoire là où tu
parles de la nation ça c'est une
pratique que je vois de plus en plus
utilisées et qui est extrêmement
respectueuse pas ce que ça veut dire on
n'est pas juste en train de nommer une
nation on est en train de parler de la
nation est en train de s'informer et ça
c'est vraiment un pas en avant vers
cette réconciliation
alors merci beaucoup karine pour ta
question
j'espère y avoir répondu n'hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo il n'hésitait pas à
nous envoyer des questions sur une belle
semaine